تاثيرات الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاده راويه
ومشاهدينا ليست عسكريه فحسب لها جانب
سياسي بحسب تقرير لواشنطن بوست في الجانب
العسكري يزداد القلق بين اوساط النخبه
الروسيه بشان الاسلحه الغربيه المقدمه
لاوكرانيا وما اذا كانت قادره على قطع
مناطق سيطره روسيا في الشرق الاوكراني
والممتده حتى شبه جزيره القرم الصحيفه
نقلت عن مسؤولين روس قولهم ان الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا حتى وان لم تنضم
فسيجعلها دوله بجيش حديث تشكل تهديدا
وجوديا لروسيا واشنطن بوست قالت ان روسيا
كانت تعتمد على عامل الوقت وتراجع العزم
الغربي لدعم اوكرانيا خاصه مع امتداد امد
الحرب واحتمال انخفاض مستويات مساعده
اوكرانيا الا ان الوضع على الارض غير
الصوره فهجمات الطائرات المسيره على موسكو
والتوغلات داخل الاراضي الروسيه اثار
التساؤلات حول مدى قدرات الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين على السيطره على الوضع وفق مس لم
يكشفوا عن اسمائهم ورغم تعرض المناطق
الحدوديه الروسيه مثل بلغرود لقصف مكثف
وهجمات سعى الكرملين الى التقليل من تاثير
تلك الهجمات مع تقليل تغطيه التوغلات على
التلفزيون الحكومي لكنه امر لم يمنع من
تصاعد الاستياء احدى علامات توتر النخبه
ظهرت عندما اعلن عضو البرلمان الروسي
بدايه الشهر الجاري فشل اهداف روسيا التي
لم تتحقق في اوكرانيا كالقضاء على النازيه
هناك ونزع سلاحها ووضعها في حاله حياد
التقرير نقل عن مصدر مقرب من الدوائر
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه قوله ان موسكو ربما
ستظهر اشارات متواضعه على انها قد تكون
مستعده لتقديم بعض التنازلات كما نقلت
واشنطن بوست عن دبلوماسي روسي قوله ان
مسار الصراع في اوكرانيا قد تكون له عواقب
غير متوقعه على روسيا بشكل عام وعلى مكانه
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين بشكل خاص
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات